I'll tell you what I meant this is  annoying really because uh I'm in the  worst place possible for it big asses  Latino women you like big ass Latina  women yeah like huge thick women I know  I like that yeah yeah what do you mean  something I want something like that  other men go don't know about that like  I want that really yeah I want a  challenge why are you you got a piece on  you I'm not suggesting that I mean if  people want to surmise that that's up to  them what do you have I think it's quite  average if I'm honestly it's average but  but the average on you because that's  still probably right you've made a  [ __ ] good point there for years  I've been thinking about your dick since  you sat down  it's a left tone no this is the thing  right it's like if you have a huge house  with a big garage and then you have a  normal sized car it looks small that  looks weird right